which we were talking about right up
until the countdown for this honest
trailer commentary so let's switch gears
and talk about venom two um
look everybody has a different
tolerance for stupidity um
mine is high it turns out because this
movie was much dumber than venom one
and i still don't think it really
crossed the line but i know a lot of
people had uh the reaction like this
one's too dumb i'm not going with you
where this one's going i still had fun
what did you guys think of venom too oh
yeah i thought it was super fun like it
um the dumbness of the first one was
what i liked about it and i thought that
that was what works i don't want like a
serious venom movie i have no
desire to see that so
yeah like in this one they're just like
uh oh well people really liked the
lobster fish tank well let's just do
more dumb stuff and i'm like yes that's
stupid dumb stuff
in the 90s it felt like there was this
moment where maybe comic book movies
would develop in a very different
direction and it would just be like this
crazy
anarchic chaotic cartoon world that
makes up its own rules and that's the
world in which comic book movies would
take place here you've got stuff like
tanker on
spawn yes and it feels like kind of with
the x-men series then mcu we kind of
smoothed that out nolan it became like
no no no they're going to be these
outrageous stories but in a gritty
realistic in our world and i love that
venom seems to be like from an alternate
reality where it went totally the other
way and like sam raimi spider-man became
the north star for all of these movies
and uh so it's crazy and it's so
weird and kind of marching to its own
drum and doesn't really feel the need to
be like the formula and play like those
other movies and
the first one i i kind of like the first
venom this one i feel like it steers way
into that skid and i really enjoyed it
like it just feels like it's its own
thing and it doesn't feel tied to the
other franchises and i love that energy
i found it right it is refreshing i
still think that i mean and this isn't
an original critique uh but like how
much better would this be if this were
rated r and there were just torrents of
blood just uh like kill bill style just
spraying out of every time uh venom or
carnage bits someone's head off i think
that's really missing that's kind of
holding these uh i mean i felt like i
feel like i felt like there was more in
the first one and this one it's sort of
playing more into the rom-com
zany side and so i didn't feel like it
was missing the gore as much uh as like
the more action horror version i don't
mean like horror i don't mean like
horrific gore i mean funny gore you know
right the hilarious
oh my arm my arm yeah i mean i could see
some of that some of that shane black
vibe i think that would really elevate
the material as they say
um i also uh god i love that this was
co-written by tom uh by tom hardy and
and uh that he and andy circus just got
together got real deep in the story in
the script yeah these characters and
this is what they came up with it's just
yeah i mean like this gets it this gets
what venom movies should be i attribute
most of the goofiness to tom hardy yeah
he he's the one who seems to get it
because he's the one who came up with
like a lot of the the really goofy stuff
we saw which is funny because look i
don't know too much about him but he
seems like serious actor dude like he
seems like a very committed grounded
like takes the process seriously but
then you see his old myspace page and
you're like huh
this guy's better than we really
realized i interviewed him for something
and maybe it was the first venom um
dudes dude loves goofs and gaffs um for
sure
and maybe it's the nolan association
right think of him as like a more uh
internal you know solid grounded actor
but he could also be just getting inside
the character you know if it's a dark
character then yeah he's gonna take it
to a very dark and severe place but if
you're playing eddie brock and venom
that's you know he's going to bring that
energy to the project and i think it
might it might be more of a case by case
yeah i wonder if he does his own uh it
pops his own wheelies on that motorcycle
man that guy loves to pop a wheel he
does
enjoys a wheelie yeah uh all right well
let's pop a wheelie ourselves and uh
ride off into the sunset of venom two
electric boogaloo
[Music]
from the company who can't make their
own spider-man movie or streaming
service oh or
it's already been pointed out and uh
shame on us uh sony made spider-verse so
they can clearly make their own
spider-man movie should have caveated
that with live action
um okay
you guys get it's a joke
it's not this is this is the wikipedia
we strive for honesty
honesty accuracy integrity someone
someone tell me what that is in latin
and that that'll be our crest
uh because yeah we you know we we want
it we want our jokes to we don't want
them to be more than a kernel of
premises of course of course but that
yeah
there's a lot
we're not perfect shockingly we're not
perfect um
keep going service or enough ps5s comes
the one thing sony can still deliver
a top-notch galleon rom-com you are a
bottom
venom let there be heartache that's a
good cause that's
in the film there's a
that's a timely cut because i believe he
calls him a bottom feeder
uh the magic of editing all right keep
going film about a squirrely guy who
talks to himself you call gollum to
direct it andy circus helms 2021 sequel
to 2018 surprise hit of 1996
packed with bad cgi goo
bad wigs you said it and british actor
is doing really bad so yeah the wig work
on michelle williams uh danielle care to
comment
it's better this time around uh the
venom the venom one wig was tragic it is
better this time around but it's still
i just there there there are so many you
go on instagram and you watch like the
wig work of like
women who are doing it for free for
themselves like on their own and it's
amazing how much better it is than
hollywood would work it's it's
you know i don't understand like is it
just cuz that character would never have
like short hair like why can't michelle
williams has lovely hair why why why do
you gotta do that
well i think in the first one she had
short hair and then
i don't think that that character
it's not like a gwen stacy where she's
got like a very specific kind of hair
yeah
yeah yeah it's just hair like you can do
whatever and i'm kind of forgetting the
the nitty-gritty details of venom one
but didn't she she was like the lawyer
responsible for like
covering the tracks of the
space villain right like
was it riz ahmed uh it was on men
she was a lawyer like covering up for
his human experimentation stuff
so she she turned out fine right didn't
she work for him i don't know because
like eddie searched her files um
and that was why they broke up you you
might be right i i'm not saying this is
not true i'm just saying i don't i don't
really remember venom 2 is a blissfully
consequence-free universe that people
have been and i'm glad to see uh she
landed on her feet didn't get in any
trouble
um i'm sure she didn't know what was
really going on
uh okay anyways keep playing and british
actors doing really bad american accents
okay this is about me wanting to live
without you whining in my ear all the
time about eating bad guys i just
incapacitated your boyfriend and only
you at the life foundation when that
rocket exploded wait is this what it
sounds like to them
no turkish is uh he's in snatch but
turkish is jason statham right right
yeah but the guy that's like uh like dog
stink like the guy that has that scene
yeah yeah
yeah i like diggs yeah steven graham is
the actor's name he was really good at
the irishman uh
that's crazy movement he's the guy that
i don't know maybe shorts to the meeting
obviously uh as americans we know little
to nothing about uh the world so who are
we to talk but um
it's funny that they just think like
sounding like you're from new york or
boston or whatever but you live in san
francisco it's like that's what cops
sound like right they sound like
brooklyn cops yeah we've kind of got
like one of every american stereotype in
san francisco because also you got then
you've got uh carnage who's like a
southern rockabilly
yeah
yeah all of them should be talking like
the californians if anything right
that doesn't uh i also i got i got an
answer for you thanks to fandom.com and
their collection of wikis and herself
did not work for the life foundation but
her company did so that was how eddie
was able to use her computer to access
files about carlton drake played by rizz
ahmed but it was not her personal uh
phew okay i was worried restless
all right keep playing wait is this what
it sounds like to them when i go oh mary
poppins which way to the queen
catch up with eddie brock and his
parasite venom to
roommates who spend every minute coming
in and out of each other eddie's
journalism career has stalled because
he's an idiot it's a house
just like about his his journalism
career
first of all i thought he was like a
blogger in the first one like it was
like the brock the brock report or
whatever he had a very successful
youtube
expose investigative series i think it
was funny that throughout this movie
they kept saying like other reporters
and news stories would be like eddie
brock is back on top of the reporting
game yeah that's not how reporting even
works they just kept talking about him
as a reporter as part of their stories
which yeah it's like being a bouncer in
the roadhouse universe where they're all
like i hear you're the best reporter
like nobody outside the bouncing
community knows other bouncers and where
they are in the pecking order but yeah
well look i i i i'm constantly just
talking about how good someone's new
reporting is and like how they're back
on their reporting game that's all me
and my friends talk about when we're at
the hipster coffee shop yeah anytime
there's a gathering in our industry it's
like i hear you're the best joke writer
about venom movie
eric goldman back on top
with that new junket
um anyways uh just uh just a fun little
aside all right keep talking yeah and
venom just can't help killing people
another one bites the dust
they had families enjoy their wacky
dynamic where venom reacts in real time
to eddie's crappy life you suck you're
shocked excuse me and ignore how awkward
it must be for the people who can't hear
his voice congratulations thank you
nicely done kevin we should do a whole
venom without yeah venom without bed
[Laughter]
as this film leans hard into the simrock
shippers fantasies to make a gayer
superhero movie than the one with actual
gay superheroes in it hello gorgeous
sorry no you're not my type you just
said
that you love me
um
i am out
of the eddy closet
what has been a mistake
they knew what they were doing they know
exactly what they're doing and they did
it for me they did it specifically for
me and thank you
well i mean again extremely intentional
yeah like even if it's like mcgruber
style this should have been rated r so
we could have finally seen
a love scene between ben and eddie and i
mean every scene between venom and eddie
is already a love scene there's no way
they can be more intimate
i think that the possibilities are truly
endless um and uh we saw this a little
bit remember we i think i think dan and
i talked about this on charting even
where they were promoting the first
venom movie in china with sort of like
you know kind of cutesy romantic sort of
like it's a love story about eddie and
venom like it feels like in a weird and
i can't believe i'm going to say this it
feels like a natural evolution of that
relationship in some ways as odd as it
may be to describe or watch visually but
yeah it's obviously very on purpose and
uh well handled i thought i think yeah
yeah it doesn't feel like it's over the
top or like hitting you over the head
with it it's just this is an aspect of
eddie and venom's personality it really
is a rom-com except like instead of uh
the big new year's eve uh party it's
like him fighting another goo
another goo
yeah it's really more like there is this
this story about carnage and you know
like that that rivalry but it's more
about eddie and venom learning
boundaries and how to live together than
it is about the the fighting like it's
it's i'd say an hour out of the 90
minutes is the eddie venom relationship
as opposed to maybe 30 about cletus
cassidy and his girlfriend yep
uh all right keep playing we'll get
venom is pushed to the brink by the only
guy named cletus to get an interracial
marriage he began life as a twilight
reject lip-syncing to woody harrelson
they can't take you from me you're my
one
right like then became a monster
infected by the guy fieri virus which um
[Music]
hands
i was just very particular about that
because you know i like my triple d so i
want to make sure we got the twang
exactly right and uh that the sign was
over the proper shot of the red
convertible
um where my guy heads at come on i wanna
i need no i need to immediately i mean
the first time you see him with that car
you're like is he is he they must have
like they had a photo of guy yeti at the
makeup station like give me one of those
but also a weird his timeline doesn't
make sense i mean unless he's like a
like a swing revivalist guy
like he's like into rockabilly like in a
in a retro ironic way because he was a
reverend horton 90s guy he was like
he's a teenager in prison in the in the
in 96 is when that flashback is and he
gets out
i don't know i have a question about
ages when it comes to him and years
later and he becomes woody house
yeah tough but it's tough living
yeah
you know it doesn't it doesn't perfectly
line up no but yeah like why would you
maybe he was really into the last thing
he did before he went into an
institution was he saw like pulp fiction
or reservoir dogs and he just really got
into like you saw like a reverend horton
heat social d show and was like romance
it reminds me very much of that scene
and i'm gonna get you sucka where the
dude comes out and he's in all of his
pimp gear yes and he's got like the
goldfish in the shoe and it's like
because that's what he was wearing when
he like came went in yeah it's like i
only want shirts with flames going up at
least half of them but there's not
cartoon flames coming from the sleeves
and bon i don't want it not
good for him yeah good for cletus okay
keep going on a rampage to elope with
shriek who's marvel's answer to dc's
black canary except she um see the the
difference is that uh
okay i guess he's just dc's black canary
and nothing can stop these two lovebirds
from being together except fire
or sound
or the fact that her superpower is
making loud noises
see this is why truffles are so hard to
balance that's why michelle williams got
sidelined in this wood i just needed a
little space after the whole
alien biting a guy's head off thing
died in an ever-expanding
delivery that's that's a pro right there
yeah i mean you're you're never gonna
find somebody to come in and do a hey
that happened joke better than oscar
winner four-time nominee yeah four-time
oscar nominee michelle
yeah and then just regards to the
earlier part like it really limits the
uh
threat and the scope of a venom in in
the mcu or beyond when you can just make
a loud noise and he's like i can't
handle this
yeah
he gets defeated by church bells in like
three movies that he's a thing a thing
to work on for venom three for sure it's
like okay he's gotta have something he
can do about this
earmuffs yeah i'd be cute
um okay keep playing i've been to an
ever expanding universe of the ip still
controlled by sony pictures until
morbius eats dirt at the box office and
they start from scratch again featuring
some of marvel's most iconic buildings
newspaper names and metaphors
until they just give up at the end and
blip venom into the mcu or whatever in a
move that thrilled mainstream comic book
nerds while the real eagle-eyed dorks
are trying to figure out why venom
crosses over with beverly hills cop too
wait are we finally getting a cinematic
eddie verse why
why has he dressed the entire movie like
axel foley
i honestly feel like it's just a it's
just a reference like that's a that's a
comedy action sequel they liked and so
it was just like
tip of the tip of my cap
but it's like the whole movie he's
wearing either the mumford phys ed thing
or the yeah and plus the lions jacket oh
he definitely i did not notice until
until somebody else pointed it out i did
not notice this connection but he's
definitely in it the whole movie yeah
and then well he actually briefly
changes into it the reason i noticed it
was he's like briefly in a uh like a
golden state warrior shirt and he's in a
detroit lion shirt i'm like that's
that's a pretty chaotic uh fan hood like
i love the detroit lions and the golden
state warriors i mean if you grew up in
in michigan and then moved to san
francisco that would make sense yeah and
i was thinking oh that so that must like
explain the accent or something like
that then i looked up eddie brock
detroit or whatever and then it turned
out that like oh is that uh beverly
hills cop yes it's exactly the the
outfit actually
and not even in the first one it barely
heals
he wears the mumford thing in both right
so it's a yeah it's like but it's beyond
homage that's just his costume that's
his that's what he wears and i don't
think he's from michigan in the movie
unless they definitely have not set that
up specifically in the movie that he's
from detroit right yeah
that's like you know for for ladies they
make those doctor who dresses that you
can just go around looking like doctor
who all day
so it's eddie purposefully has modeled
his style on actually yeah
i just want to see him put a banana in
someone's tailpipe
cletus's tailpipe and then hide around
the corner and watch him
be great uh but once they kiss judge
reinhold in the mcu then this is going
to clash
venom crosses over with beverly hills
cop too wait are we finally getting a
cinematic eddie verse oh man the
possibilities are endless
so enjoy the first comic book film in a
long while that understood the
assignment that doesn't try to imitate
some other genre or stuff itself with
oscar-worthy pretensions just 90 minutes
of dumb fun about a reporter in love
with his tapeworm still would have been
even better if they had the courage to
end to just one scene earlier
this guy
see that
and one extra scene that didn't mean
then he's with bitties i support my
large adult son michelle williams after
venom one oh god i'm never doing that
again god will maybe never i don't know
honestly it's really fun fleta is the
snake
hall attack girl
and another british tomboy
man venom's got to type doesn't he
yeah pause look up tom hardy's uh old
myspace photos if you if you want a
cheap thrill you dare yeah if you dare
yeah it seemed like he was having a good
time in the early 2000s as we all were
um all right great time to be alive
let him carnage
how does venom keep sprouting tentacles
out of betty's back without ripping
holes in his clothes wait is venom just
pretending to be tom hardy's clothes and
he's actually naked the entire time oh
man whew this just got even hotter
i saw someone putting a comment that
like the he can go between the fibers of
the clothes so yeah there's your camera
i was go i actually had like an email
response halfway written where it's like
i actually believe that venom can move
on a microscopic level around it because
then i was like what am i what am i
doing with my life
i'm going to let this resolve itself and
not intervene
this is our yes i believe that's ours
i think that person is actually correct
yes yeah i feel like there's microscopic
even in like a a leather
uh detroit lions bomber jacket they're
still microscopic yeah
he's oozing around the fibers not going
through them he can use he can always
use he's a loser he's an user
he's an user baby
um okay uh let's do some deleted jumps
and scenes if we got any while the real
eagle-eyed dorks are trying to figure
out why venom crosses over with downton
abbey game of thrones a red
wedding
starring
eddie
so many snacks so little time it's about
ethics and serial killer journalism
four-time oscar-nominated actress
michelle williams
the goop troop
when hardy met scary
couldn't figure out perfect one there
yeah um i tried a lot of when blankie
met blankie because it's such a it is
like a rom-com but i couldn't that was
as close as i got it
it was also really it was too tough to
follow to even like write about it like
what cletus's beef with uh
eddie was and because it was like he
uncovered
where the bodies were hiding but he was
trying
he had been there to give him a message
for shriek specifically yeah and while
they were walking by his cell venom
figured out based on his doodles where
the bodies were buried but then his
doodle's in plain sight he just drawn on
the walls where he hit him you could
just not doodle on the wall where you
left the evidence against but then he
would but when he confronted him he was
mad that he didn't report on how he was
abused growing up like that was his
problem
he was like you didn't tell them about
why my grandma was was mean to me and
that's why i killed her like that was
his it was like a media bias thing
that's what set him off
yeah
it doesn't really i feel like they kind
of wrote themselves into a corner with
venom one where they wanted to set up
cletus cassidy but they didn't have a
good idea of how they were going to use
them so they had to like make this fit
that thing they'd already done and this
was the best they came up with it uh the
good news is it does not matter at all
no it's it's a total afterthought in
this movie which is really much more
about like the odd couple but with eddie
brock and ben
just going through my notes looking at
other things that we didn't manage to
mention he talks to chickens a lot more
than you'd expect
this movie
well yeah his his plan is that venom
should feed on chicken brains instead of
human brains
but then venom bonds with chickens
yeah
yeah that's that's about it um yeah
cletus's age is completely indeterminate
um
i mean i feel like yeah as written the
character is like my age like would be
in his 40s and what he
rules of like how they reproduce it's
like you can just bite someone with it
and then you and then that creates a new
one and you get it unclear
i think that's the only time we've ever
seen that happen yeah but i guess
nobody's ever like bitten eddie and
sucked his blood
otherwise so morbius yeah right well
that's good let's go on to these
there's a lot of questions coming up uh
maybe we'll address this stuff uh
further susvera just asked why are the
symbiote reproduction rules so weird
i've never heard in universe reason for
it yeah i don't think we have had one
the the
comics one is there from outer space
like they're just parasites from outer
space
uh adam halbert asks uh should venom
three just be about venom and eddie
raising a carnage baby seems logical to
add parenting to the relationship yes uh
i like i think that's the logical
progression i think so it definitely
needs to be a family a family one next
time uh tara dulles love the show but
you guys should talk about arcane
that's not this week
we're talking about venom i'm gonna do
that
i hear it i haven't watched it but that
league of legends animated netflix yeah
they say
i've heard good things
um eventually am says venom 2 is what
pacific rim 2 should have been yeah i
mean pacific rim 2 is certainly dumb
enough um
but not not fun enough uh i don't
nothing really stood out about that
movie i remember we combined that honest
trailer with tomb raider because each of
them were like half interesting
um yeah
yeah i agree though i like if you're
gonna do anything like pacific rim they
kind of went with
more
world building and make it more
complicated and elaborate and if they
had instead steered into the like dopey
b movie fun version it probably would
have been better yeah i agree with that
uh adam halbert uh again says uh it's
this is why i don't like did like venom
joining the mcu now we may lose that
earnest stupidity for weak whedon quips
yeah i hope that it would be sad to see
him go well that just happened
he's standing right behind me isn't he
i can't wait to see him with like a uh
with one of those holographic touch
screens though
yeah yeah just like reporting in
get venom and audi
oh man but the yeah just the pairings of
venom and and really anyone could be
could be fun but i hope they let tom
hardy write his own dialogue i feel like
right venom would be like pop in have a
joke or two and then get out i don't
feel like he's ever gonna be one of the
like people calling in for like the
avengers zoom calls or whatever like
he's not gonna be on that level in the
mcu i don't know what those ten rings
are don't call again
uh jeffy elberton s um or says uh i i
don't think this is an accurate
portrayal of the comic book character
not really uh does but does that matter
if you like the finished product or do
you owe something to the fans or the
fans of the original
i mean
you don't owe something per se but like
i don't know i think it just leaves it
open for uh other interpretations
because you know on a long enough
timeline we get every version of every
comic book character and i do think that
uh someone will make a
more true to the original hard r venom
at some point
also i think that comic book fans are
because i think that a lot of people are
locked into the way that it was in the
90s but comic books are constantly like
changing and evolving and growing if
you're still like reading them and so it
makes sense that the movies are going to
maybe do something different or try
something different because that usually
happens every time a creative team comes
in they wind up changing up stuff and
doing different stuff so i think of a
lot of it is a lot of people were
reading them in the 90s and then like
have not kept up with it um
because like yeah i'm used to like
things always changing in comics it's
just how it works there's there's that
trope there's that idea that adaptations
are somehow like easier like oh
hollywood's out of idea so they're just
gonna take this old thing and reinvent
it now and this is one of those reasons
that it's actually as hard if not harder
to take something that already exists
because you're always like kind of
breaking it down and then reassembling
it to make something new in this case
like it's taking an older comic book and
making it a 2021
action comedy movie and like that's
always going to be different i don't
think you owe the previous version
anything because it still exists i think
your job is to take a look at what
you're making right now and take that
the elements of that that work best and
add new stuff and make it something new
i i don't think it really works
to try to like slavishly recreate the
other form anyway i think that's how you
get stuff like that ben affleck
daredevil movie like we've seen what
what happens when they try to just take
it from the page and like slap it onto a
movie screen
yeah i mean you do pick and choose what
to adapt and what and what not to i just
do think that there's still still meat
on the bone for a uh you could do the
grim dark horror version of venom and i
think that would oh sure there are other
open interpretations for venom i'm sure
and like the first movie i i think venom
2 works a lot better but the first movie
had more of a like body horror
psychological thriller element and i
definitely think that could work in a
different in a different movie i'm just
saying like i don't think you have any
responsibility to be like oh you have to
do this exactly the way it was in that
old comic book even if you respect and
admire the old comic book
well said well said um evan j pretzel
asks uh if this were made in 96 what duo
would have been eddie and venom he says
seagal and jim carrey
even by 96 seagal like couldn't really
move
he was getting a little
slower um
yeah
yeah carrie would have been a good
veteran though i mean that's that's kind
of a no-brainer sure um nick cage i'm
sorry would have been a fantastic eddie
brock cage and carrie wow that would
have been wow yeah yeah yeah no that's
that i think we've i think we've i think
we've cracked it folks i don't know if
we can get any i don't know if we can
get any green lights
um okay jones work with jim carrey again
that's what we got to do tommy lee jones
could have been carnage but uh even
older carnage um
i feel like i i i don't even want to see
tommy jones in this movie i want to see
footage of someone explaining the
character of carnage
yeah uh
who would carnage have been like
charlie rocket or something like that
i can't even think of like who would be
like the young like jessie camp
oh god wow chaos that's a poll that's a
chaotic choice
uh tv you want to be a vj winner jessie
camp folks yeah
uh arthur bingo asked that how bad will
morbius beat next year i think very bad
because i think you were taking the
uh
the vibe of venom like the the 90s era
of a comic book movie and taking the fun
and funniness out of it instead of tom
hardy being squirly and making jokes
with the symbiote you have
jared leto doing a vampire thing that
i've they released that clip and it's
like
generic it's just so generic it's like
the you got the the team of operators on
the boat they're like who's getting free
and then he like slashes them one by one
and then he pisses at the camera and
it's like i've seen every single shot in
this movie before including um
everything with jared leto snarling at
me
this is going to suck right
i'm trying very hard not to make any
judgments until it comes out but i uh
this is not going to be one i'm going to
see uh first day in theaters i i think
intentionally there's there's very low
chance that this movie is going to be
intentionally good in the way that it
means to be good
right however
i feel like there's a pretty decent
chance that this is going to be like
very successful as
campy schlock like okay fair fair jared
leto's taking it very seriously and
that's the magic ingredient like if it's
really bad and he's really living it 110
it could be kind of great and there is
that there the only moment in the
trailer is when he like vampires out and
scares the guy and then he's like oh no
hi nice to meet you i'm dr michael
morbius like that's very funny and if
they can manage like that balance for
the whole time and i'm not saying
they're going to okay i think there is a
chance that this could be a lot of fun
unintentionally there is a chance you're
saying there's a chance say there's a
chance yeah
um you know like like jared leto's house
of gucci performance like not a lot of
people defending it on its merits but a
lot of people defending it as like a
hoot
do we think okay well we'll end with
this omar laura s uh so in this uh third
spider from tom holland spiderman movie
um they have a ton of villains let's go
let's put down our marker is venom gonna
pop up in
no way home or not
you gotta call it right now you're
saying yes i i think yes i think that
that that that post-credit which wants
this movie to set up whatever happens in
no way hope that would be my guess
danielle you're saying yes to yeah i
think i think it would be a post-credits
scene i don't think that he's gonna be
like involved in the whole thing yeah i
don't think he's like a main character
but there's that is there going to be a
moment or a scene or a tease of like
more venom and spider-man mixing it up
in the future
yeah i think so okay
you know have him on that i mean they're
going to jamison they're in the same
reality like right like like as of this
movie so it's all the balls in sony okay
well then i'll say yes and i'll go one
further that there will be a scene where
he talks to tom hall and like an actual
scene between the two of them fighting
or teaming up
no i'm gonna say teaming up i'm gonna
say teaming up they want they want venom
to be uh you know the lethal protector
so he's gonna actually help in the end
in fact it's not gonna be
andrew garfield and uh um uh what's the
other one come on toby mcguire will be
on toby mcguire it's gonna be venom in
carnage
at the end he's punching lizard in that
yeah i don't care that carnage is dead
he's gonna throw throw up carnage yeah
and woody harrelson is gonna emerge from
the goo yeah multiverse carnage it's
another universe's carnage yeah yeah
exactly uh one more good one came in
right under the wire uh pericles dragon
balls ass uh not counting howard the
duck i'm not sure why what's in your
opinion the worst marvel comics movie
ever made
not an mcu just anything based on a
marvel comic
it's got to be new mutants right
that's pretty bad pretty bad and like
you know worst from like a craft
perspective is probably uh
the captain america 1990
yeah yeah
i don't i don't know i mean that that's
got like a
sweetness to it that i think sort of
keeps it out of the absolute like direct
bottom range yeah yeah i don't know i
mean my my first instinct is is that
electra i already bashed the daredevil
movie that electro movie with jennifer
garner that followed up on it was uh
that that one is pretty bad like i'm
having trouble the other one that i was
thinking of is that josh fantastic four
which actually is not terrible for no no
no 40 minutes or so and then and then
drop softly
and it was like one of the most
disappointing third acts ever so
i think i'll probably go with that one
yeah i mean and there's like that fan
really stick one fan four stick is
pretty yeah yeah
um
and there was a really bad uh
uh captain america even pre-1990 where
he has like the giant ping pong ball
helmet uh yes yes it was like the yeah
that dolph lundgren punisher is i think
it's good but i could see why people
would not yeah uh but yeah it's got that
also entertaining yeah i would not put
howard the duck on the list of the worst
because it's so weird that it's like
that makes it unique and singular and so
it's worth maybe blade trinity because
blade trinity is like they've kind of
given up and they've kind of betrayed
what was good about it and wesley
completely gave us not want to be there
yeah that one's pretty bad any movie
with jessica biel like putting in her
ipod and then slashing vampires to the
rhythm of the group is like you're
you're you're on thin ice movie
all right well there you have it um i
hope you all enjoyed this episode of
australia commentaries uh
we will uh
not god that one's too obvious
um next week we will
uh
just my expression is the is the clue
[Laughter]
on face palm um
yeah well we'll see uh if it's as
popular as they say it is next week
that's what we'll see uh i hope you come
back next time uh for another honest
trailer commentaries thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you